cette décision ne comptait pas ans
l'attendait avec impatience
et aujourd'hui quand même c'est quand
même bon ou une décision qui vient
pallier nos espoirs
d'autant plus que cela temps d'une
période très difficile
vous ne conseil d'état les étudiants
étrangers peuvent bénéficier bénéficier
éventuellement des frais notre
génération est en même temps des aides
de l'état
mais en réalité la situation des
étudiants étrangers et à ces
problématiques parce que on doit
travailler pour subvenir à leurs besoins
on doit payer le loyer et les frais qui
ont été demandés notamment la licence
occupe 270 aller jusqu'à 2700 euros et
pour le masters de 240 points jusqu'à
3700 euros
donc c'est des frais qui sont
extrêmement excessif et on pourra voir
cet argent qu'il faut notamment de faire
des économies sur plusieurs années et
est convenu de la situation actuelle
c'est un bonus une décision qui ne le
conforte pas du tout parce que ça fait
deux ans qu'on se mobilise à deux ans
qu'on dénonce une discrimination parce
que commencer vraiment un disque images